what is um obviously working with benny
on the project who else is on
karma three um i got a
popcorn on there record with popcorn i
got
uh mary j blige on there oh [ __ ]
mary got a joint um trey songz
uh trying to think who i was rapping
um though i got doughboy on there boy we
just shot the video
matter of fact a couple days ago out
here um
trying to think about something you know
the expectations for that merry record
is gonna be crazy since you played
method man
that's right this one is one of them
it's one i mean you played math the man
in the in the show on
um not this one not this one it's crazy
me and me i've got
a new record though um um static
selective
static is that guy he and mf going crazy
on that [ __ ] he got to put that out
though status it's a static record
he got the record here yo static man i
just want to give some props to him
because he's like our modern day primo
bro and he's been one thing i can salute
salute this stat
he's from day one always been like the
same way with me like before i denied a
situation
he was always in tune with me you know i
mean shout outs to static 100